Thank you.
So,
so let me ask you another question about
that then.
So she,
one of the problems that I've had
because I've been trying to look out at
the,
the potential for our true relationship
between Islam and Christianity.
You know,
to the degree that I understand Islam or
Christianity,
which of course there's plenty to
understand about both.
So it's no easy thing to manage.
But there is this claim as well that,
that that's widespread and rather vague
that that Islam is in essence a religion
of peace.
And,
but when I look at the historical data,
say stemming from Medina,
the Medina time and then moving forward
and the fact that Muhammad was
definitely someone who engaged
personally in warfare and in an
expansionist warfare,
it's not,
it's not an easy thing for me to make
the leap to uh,
to comprehending or being able to accept
the claim that the fundamental doctrines
of Islam are peaceful,
are,
are associated with piece.
Because it looks to me like there's an
element of it that's quite militaristic.
And I've also thought that,
let's say there's a religious element to
Islam.
And I mean this is not an original
thought.
Obviously there's a religious element to
Islam,
but there's also something that's
clearly more like a political movement
and more like a governmental movement.
And that's also complicated by the fact
that there isn't any clear separation
between church and state in Islamic
doctrine as far as I can tell.
So when we hear claims that are,
when claims are made that Islam is
essentially a religion of peace,
then that doesn't seem to be the case
with the Medina end of the theological
discourse or the actions that that
emerged thereof.
And then part of the problem is how do
you reconcile that with the
contradictions in relationship to the
earlier,
as you say,
Meccan doctrines and it isn't clear to
me how that can be done.
So
mostly as a political community that the
believers should.
Of course,
they are in that position today.
Right?
Right.
That did not give you the lessons
choice.
He's insane.
Or can have your brides are like,
his message was you guys are Washington
follow spots.
These are items you live in a time and
signals and I left the last message
conveyed to you
the light and enlightenment and come
with me.
No please.
[inaudible] records.
Lots of messages.
It's the fact that cooking apply of
course,
fortunately the other end of the mixture
attacker,
the records described
in Rosina,
yes he does that
walk the wall.
The numbers were [inaudible] and these
are people who come from of them.
Then you see everywhere where people
access as law,
that is destination seniors live only
after you accept Islam.
As long as you refused to abide by
Islamic law or accept to be subdued by
Islam,
you are at war.
That's why they limit make this
distinction between the House of Islam
and the House of war.
Right.
And the House of war is everywhere where
there are infidels and it's the job of
the Muslims and the house of peace to
convert.
So it's a religion of peace in so far as
it's final utopian aim is the cessation
of conflict,
but it's the cessation of conflict in
part as a consequence of of conquest.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well,
that was more or less how I understood
it.
So when the claim is made that it's a
religion of peace,
then that isn't precisely,
it's,
it's a slight of hand in some sense.
With regards specifically to that
phrase.